[音楽]
n ame
こんにちは
30年前
私はここへ務めたんですね
それでインターネットを作るという日本のネットワークを世界とつないで
へ
世界中で力を合わせてインターネットを作り始めたんですけれども
その出発点はココで
このキャンパスをずっと不インターネットでつなごうって言うんでやってたんです
けれども
その時私常習だったんですけど東大の
それでこの安田講堂を繋ごうとしたら怒られるんですね
立っ今日もねあのて dx の方達ね大変だと思いますよこれ
ここでねいきなり阿波踊りですからね
これは相当怒られるんじゃないかと思いますけれども
あのかなり30年前はもっとすごくてですね
もうここにネットワークを貼るとかネットワークある時はケーブルの穴を貼らなきゃ
いけないね
でこの穴をあけるとかとんでもないですねであの
しょうがないので誰もいない夜中にこっそり開けなきゃいけなかったんですけど
まあいずれにせよですねインターネットを作るっていうのはあのそうやってみんな
一人一人の手で
まあ30年前から作り始めまして今は皆さんは普通に使ってる
これがインターネットですよねそれでまあそこには今このエンゲージメント院で
インターネット
もうねインターネットをつくってくる人を動かしている人っていうのは今でもたくさん
の人がいてそれでこの人たちが誰でどうやってるかそれが今日はパイオニア ring
the future
皆さん
はこれから未来を生きていくときにこの事がどういうふうに関係をしていくのかそう
いうお話を今日は
しようと思いますまずインターネットって何だろうと云われると皆さんもいろんな
ことを答えられるんじゃないかと思いますね
インターネットはでインターネットって言ったり
それからネットっていう時もありますねダーンレッドっていう時もありますこれで
カタカナだとインターネットで書きますよね私もこのインターネットっていうカタカナ
でたくさんの本を書いたりしてたんですけれども
もまずかったなって思うことなんですね
なんだかわかりますこれよーく見ると
でいえインターネット
えっとそして方からのインターネットですこれね
d
インターネットっていうのは
定冠詞ですよねキャプターライズ合いが大きいでしょう
地球にをしかないんです
ネットってそれの省略形だから n がキャプチャライズされてるんですよ
真ん中で使われてもだから一個しかないことが分かるんです
カタカナでいうとなんとなくそれがボケちゃうんですよね
で誰もどうしようもなかったですね日本語だとあのこれしかなかったッ
で一つしかないということをいら切れあの表現するできないんですね
それでインターネットはじゃあなんで1つしか前のかというとこれは tcp ip
っていう
プロトコールでつながるコンピューターはいっぱいあるんですけれども
今だったら8 t だからどんな方も伝わってるんですけれども
これが地球場前
不つながっていて連結して必ずあるつないだものは別のつながっているものときちんと
話すことができる
これがインターネットの条件ですからそうでないものはインターネットって言わないん
ですよっていうことはインターネットは地球2個しかないです
逆に言うと今すべての地域ですべての国で
そしてすべての人がインターネットを使えるようになった
ほぼまだまだやらなきゃいけないことあるんですけどねそれでそうするとそこまで
だいたいそんな感じがあるこの部屋の中にインターネットを使ったことをない人はい
ないと思うんですよでここ
までまあたった30年でここまで来たんですから
これは白球がものすごく速かったですよね
それでこれでえっとじゃあここまできたら私たちはこれから未来をどうやって開拓する
のか
これが今日のこの3セッションのテーマでもあるわけです
さてもうちょっと見てみましょうかえっとインターネット私がこのキャンパスにいて
そして色々な企業をつないだり大学をつないで歩いは世界とうまくつなぐこういう工夫
をしながらやってきてまインターネットの基盤ができていきました
それでまあさっき安田講堂で怒られたのは大したことないんです
けれどもいろいろなそういう
例えば
もっといろんなことが&これ youtube 残るので誘われあるんですけれども
我慢できないから言っちゃいますけど
国立大学を民間企業とつなきゃいけないってありましたね
それでというわけで東大は企業とせないじゃいけないといけないんですけれども
でも企業から来共同研究をもらわないとをかねえ大改正日なんて洗えないですからね
どぉすればいいんだろうって思ったらですね意外な魔法の方法がありましたねこれも
あんまり言っちゃいけないんですけど言いますね今日
せっかくだからあのですね岩波書店に行ってですね
神田の家並み書店ってつなぎますって言ったんですよ
どの企業も全部ダメだって言われたんですけども東京大学の先生たちは
岩波書店はいいよって言うんです
このねアカデミズムのなんか弱さがあるんですけども
それでもうじゃあやろうと思って企業の音ルータを全部家並みに集めて
それで東大はの人1本だけつないで最初のインターネットを作ったんです
それでまあそういう苦労はまだ理解されてない時だから
今日みたいにみんながインターネットつなるようになってない時だからだから色々な
やはり障害がありましたまあそれを一つ一つの世界中でそれを変え
委託してたんですけれどもそのうちの子のキャンパスのまさにこの家に行ったのが私
だったということになりますインターネットは世界中をつなぎそれから立だった
ボーダーを横につなぐって言われてます
大学圧平気でつなぎますのでまさかその間に国境があるっていう意識
ありませんでしたね本当に世界中をつないでいくっていう時に
ボーダーを超えています盾を超えてますよね大学と大学をつなぐ大学と木々をつなぐの
も今言ったようにすでにボーダーを超えてるんですよ
それでこれを超えてつないでいくと何が起こるかというとそこにはコラボレーション
協調が起こります
それでその基盤をつくっているのがインターネットで今は iot とか
データが流通するからそこではコラボレーションができる
コラボレーション今昔だってできました
東京大学と早稲田大学慶応大学東京大部と共同大学これはコラボレーションでいつでも
ありますよ
昔からありましたケンブリッジ大学ハーバード大学でもそのコストがどんどんどんどん
下がってくる
つまりコラボレーションをしやすくなるこの世界をつくっているのが大学感がいいん
ちゃんとつながったからですよねだから皆さんがこれから生きていく
この時代にはこういうコラボレーションやりやすくなると思います
そしてさらにこのコラボレーションを本当にできるようになると今スマホの
アプリケーションを作る
こういうのも簡単にできるようになっていましたねポスト簡単にできると
全く新しいものが生まれてきますこれがイノベーションです
まだ浸かろう救っっていう時にはこれはこのグラウドファンディング
両方でお金を集めるこれができるようになるっていうのも
これは本当に寄付を世界中の人から集めるって難しかったと思いますよ
ただそのことは今はものすごく低いコストができるようになるつまり
コラボレーションイノベーションもとてもやりやすくなっているってことが分かり
いただけると思いますね
それでこの
今いろいろな課題もありますねあいろんなことが全部このサイバースペース
インターネットの空間で作れるようになったこれが
どうだ
これ
どこで見えてますこれ
新武器だけあっててきたヤッター
ほにねインターネットがでしょそれでこのグローバルの空間がある
こういうところでこのサイバースペースが出来てるんですけれども我々はその下の実
空間に生きていますここには国っていうのはですねグローバルとインターナシあると
いうことを違いますよね
グローバルっていうのは地球で1個だからインター
ネットが本当に準 v にもたらした空間ですけれども私たちは国と国連
そういう国際関係 international 空間にも生きてるんですね
それでここで争いが起こったり戦争が起こったりしますけれどもその点部つながって
いるのがこの空間でございますちゃって
そうしますと a ここで太鼓が灯台ですから ww
ラベル度というダッシュ桃居.ac.jp
これも私がここにいた時こういう名前にしようっていうのを決めたんですけれどもこれ
が今でも動いてますよねどうやって覚えているか知っていますこの jp っていうの
はどこに行けば ip アドレスわかりますか
ac っていうのどこに
競馬かかりますが you 東京って誰が管理してるんですか
こういう構造で動いているんですよ一番上の jp のも国家にいるのがルートって
言う
ネームサーバという仕事なんですねつまり世界の中で
まず jp ってどこって言ってるとこまでいっていくのです
それでこれがルートネームサーバーということなんですね
ルートネームサーバーこうやって世界中にに200か300あるように見えるんですが
実はこれを動か
している人たちはいろんな人たちです私たちも1個 m ってのが知ってるし
アメリカの軍も動かしている企業が動かしているのはヨーロッパで動かしているのも
これ誰もお金貰ってないんですよ
全部ボランティアで動いている
ですからインターネットってこれだけ社会基盤なのにボランティアでみんながそれぞれ
世界中でちょっとずつ力を合わせて動かしているんですそれだけじゃありません
インターネットの基盤になるのは全部電話会社がそれぞれやってるんですか
こういうふうに思う方もいらっしゃるかもしれないけれどもただこの実態はこうやって
なんでもいいんですがデジタルぞ
データを配るのはこれはインドネシアでワークショップで
村にインターネットが必要だっていうんで中華鍋と塩を入れる感と usb の
wi-fi で4 k とぶっていうことができるんですよねこれを利用して村に
インターネットを作るつまり1
より1人が必要になったところを必要な守備範囲をきちんと役割を果たすと世界の
インターネットができるんです
こういうのを自律分散システムっていますそして自律分散して強調する
つまりそれぞれがその役割を果たしてそしてあちこちにいる人たちが力
汗て同じ目的のために動くこれが自律分散協調性してもインターネットは自律分散協調
システムなんですね
そうするとじゃあこういうことで皆さんの世界の
これからの未来に何が起こるのか
こういうのを一つ例で考えましょう例えば
ものづくりってよく言いますよねものづくりはどこにあるかって言うとですねまず
インターネットの歴史予報やってあるとそこでコンピューターがこうやってどんどん
どんどん発展をしてそしてコモディティになっている
つまりコモディティっていうのはみんなのものになったからものすごく安くなったん
です
これちょっと前のコンピューターは何億円冥府しましたけれども皆さんはそれより性能
の良いものポケットに持っていますさてものづくりの
工場これも高い機械で作ってたんですよね昔はそれが今
プロフェッショナル用のものづくりがあったら今3 d プリンターの個人用
こういうのでものが作れるようになってもいいですそうなってくるとやがってはこれが
コモディティー化しますのでまあもうすでにしていると
つまり物理
的なものもこのデジタル1ターゲットの環境でへ
どんどん作れるようになる個人で作れるようになってきます
そのすると何が起こるかっていうとコストがものすごいやつなんですよ
これコストをちょっと見ていただくとものづくりの体型が
これなかなか魚ハウス難しいんですよ
いや見ててくれて左に僕が丸を作ったと思ってみてください
それで一番左がものづくり残すでしょ
真ん中はインターネットが始まってアマゾンとか行くとへいっ
この全部
ロジスティック物流はやすくなりましたよねマーケッティングやすくなりましたよね
それでこれが今はこれからはどんどんどんどんその
デジタルデータが送ると3 d プリンターで印刷すると物流も安くなりますよという
わけでものづくりと人に伝わっていくっていうのは
ものすごくコストの概念が変わると思うんですこれでそうすると今までやっぱり
たくさん作ってたくさん作ったものを人に渡すから余るものができる
こうやって無駄になるこういうことに疑問を持ってた人はこの問題を解決できるように
なります
例えば個人に合わせて作ろう
そしてあの人が欲しいものを渡し1個だけ作ってあげよう
そしてきちんと計算をしてどういう風になるかって言って2を出さないようにしよう
こういうことができるようなんですこれも一つの例ですよねというわけで私たちはこの
ものを
作る仲間たちと作るそして自分たちがきちんとそれをつくっていくということができる
ようになります
えっといくこれを見ていただくとこれは交差点でランダーバウトってなりますよね運転
手が一人一人がグルって回りながら事故を起こさないようにするっていう
こういう仕組みです
これは信号で
止めてしまうという中央の管理ではなくて一人一人が責任をもって自己物考えに運転し
ている
これが実はスペースがあれば効率が高いということがわかっているんですそれでという
わけでこれからインターネットが地球を包んだ
そして私たちの地球の環境のことを
思いをはせるとこうやって海リク
生物の発生こういうことを考えますでもこれは毛利さんが言ったんですけれども夜の
地球を見ると光が輝いて見え
私たちはこれは光はテクノロジーですよテクノロジーがやっぱりその環境だ
日本を見ると鉄
同路線図に見えるこれはテクノロジーですね
テクノロジーが私たちの環境を作り私たちはそこで未来を開拓する
こういうことができるようになるという教えだと思います私はこの a 毛利さんの
言葉に大変感謝していますけれども今
ものづくりって言ったよ皆さんが一人一人が取り組む
これからの新しい
c 開拓はこのインターネット前提とした社会の中でとても今まで出来なかったことが
やれるようになる
ここがとても大切だと思いますどんなことにも勇気を持って取り組む
そうするとその夢や課題の解決は実現することになると思います今日は聞いていたら
いってどうもありがとうございました
[拍手]